well thank you for giving me this
unconference slot and if someone has any
ideas on how to do to talk about
something else please do I'm going to
talk about visualization of machine
learning of units of measure using pi
vez actually it's not pirates it's
holidays they recently change the name
to differentiate some things that they
are doing all of it is a subset of
pirates but it's still okay to say that
I'm using pirates however I'm more
interested in talking about the project
itself that I'm visualizing what they
gave lightning talk about what I'm doing
with five is and I'm gonna repeat some
of the things here but I'm more
interested in explaining what what I'm
doing within the units of measure think
about it you know measure something that
everyone's used to seeing in high school
even like you write a physics equation
or any other equation you always have to
put in the units of measure any number
that you see well people still do it
however there's a big problem and I'm
going to show it in the in a minute or
two the problem started because I
developed disease models I'm a
computational disease modeler and I
develop diabetes model and this diabetes
model it takes a lot of information in
it from multiple sources one of the
sources it's taking into is data on
clinical trials those clinical trials
are now regulated and by law you have to
report them there's the US law if the a
law that requires supporting of a
stoical trial currently or each time you
check on clinical trials.gov which is
the registry that collects all the data
each time you check there you will find
out that there are more and more
clinical trials currently over 300,000
but the number keeps on growing in a few
months it goes and much much much larger
and much bigger but it actually changes
daily
in April however if you look only at the
clinic
Charles with results meaning with
numerical data that is interesting for
models there were roughly 36,000
clinical trials with results meaning
with numbers each clinical trial has
multiple numbers for demographics
statistics about demographics and for
representing outcomes how many people
died how many had the heart attacks and
so on and so forth in what was the
average blood pressure things like that
however if you looked at all of those
46,000 clinical trials with results you
find that there are 24,000 over 24,000
different units of measure reported
highly non standardized and the reason
is because it was written those were
written textually and humans met make
mistakes also they copy paste from the
paper the all sorts of animality is
Unicode characters you will see some of
those there in a few minutes so what I'm
trying to do I'm trying to get computers
to understand actual medical data in
data and I've been doing this for over a
decade now to get to the point that you
computers and send medical data they
will have to understand the numbers in
some points otherwise it's like oh I
understand only the text doing the NLP
no you have to understand the numbers to
run some numerical models or statistical
models so what I did is I collected
information from existing unit standards
and there are few and I'm and I'm trying
to do some machine learning that will
help map all of those units that are non
standardized to the proper standards and
also merge those standards I'll going to
show you later and currently allocated
multiple standards I'm going to show you
a little bit about this later but again
what I'm trying to do is I'm trying to
make machines understand medical medical
data how much time it would take so
let's look at other things that happen
the past that were automated the way or
not away but at least to the point a
human now
his problems competing if you look at
chess
in 1951 chewing created a tour champ
which is the first chess playing program
well it's not the full chest but it's it
started 1997 the blue wins against world
champion it's just cuz power at the time
and you can see all of the evolution in
between and if you click on this
actually and this is a five is the
option since I'm using mark down I can
include HTML I can click on this I'll
get the Wikipedia page I won't do this
now because I want to talk about
actually I did cloak a little anyway
back to my presentation so this is what
happened with computer with computer
chess let's look at driverless cars we
still don't see them in the streets
however way more commercialized last
year way mirrors the Google driverless
cars basically and after driving ten
million miles autonomously I don't think
I'm going to drive ten million miles in
my lifetime but this is the achievement
made forty years approximately after
they started experimenting with the car
that stays between two lanes so this is
approximately the amount of time that
takes for computers to solve difficult
problems the problem of solving medicine
like impersonating a doctor for a
computer will be much much tougher
because there's much more problems many
more problems of data and also the
problems with standardization chess was
basically solved by algorithms and
computing power you can argue against it
but basically this is a solution for
driverless cars you needed some machine
learning and data and sensors as well
yes you will need sensors for medicine
as well we'll have to wear some of those
but eventually if the data that we get
is standardized and there's enough of it
I believe we can get to the point that
were close enough so a computer will act
at least as good as a human or by the
fact that
can replicate computers easily at least
solve the problem of scarcity of doctors
because those have to be trained for
many years and then maintain their
knowledge and this problem if you can do
this automatically then replicated will
solve a lot of resources but for this
there are a lot of work to do and I
wrote down several models that I thought
that were important throughout time and
I don't know how much longer it's going
to be you need to solve it but when I
ask experts they tell me I think the
tall one said the 25 years and then five
movie s for policy to pull policy to
follow after that but I think this is
the the first the first time I got from
other experts maybe it will take us more
maybe some of the problems that we saw
before but this is the who at the
horizon but to get there we need to get
computers to understand before they
start running and they need to
understand the numbers they have been a
sensor thinks the doctors do they
understand and this is what I'm trying
to solve this one little step and the
solution that currently have is I went
to clinical trials.gov download the data
matched it indexed it I got all the
unique units from later on extracted
free standards from C disk C disk
actually is in here in Austin
it's a place their head cause or what
was the zoom in Austin it's a
standardization Organization for
healthcare which is global they are
actually an open source standard RT MMS
is actually a project by NIST and I
Triple E they also have a different
standard for medical devices and there's
a website called bio portal then has
unit ontology inside it so those free
those free unit standards are the base
but also within RT MMS and C disks
there's something called oakum
which is also the unified code for units
of measure which is actually also
powered also kind of a unit standards
mostly how to combine units so notice in
healthcare you have four units done
standards currently some of them will
repeat each other and this partially
explains some of the problem every
person who put in information whoever
entity will put information
clinicaltrials.gov uses a different
standard and therefore all the problem
it's a tower of babel problem so I
extract an information for all those
standards and actually merged it to the
level that some of the units I can tell
you oh there are the same across the
board and there are also synonyms for
some of them so actually have a table of
synonyms between standards and now I'm
trying to create some machine learning
that if tomorrow you come up with a unit
I want the machine learning to be able
to tell you which unit you actually
meant and I started by doing the
following things I started by looking at
natural language processing and later on
I did some machine learning and
clustered it later on I'm going to talk
about supervised machine learning as
well but what I'm showing you now is
unsupervised machine learning the first
thing I did is I took the units
themselves and for example the unit
participants with a big P and
participants with a small P this is a
common thing that happens a lot of
people just misspell different caps you
can see that there are according to a
lexical proximity they are very close to
each other
it's like proximity of one however
participants in years well they are not
the same proximity of zero so I'm
showing this heat map here and notice
how nicely I can go around the the cells
here and show you exactly what I'm
looking at this is a hall of use
capabilities all of yous
sits on top of bocalee in this situation
and allows you to do this nice heat map
and allow you to have this interaction
in this presentation and this
presentation is in fact
a webpage so I can show it but I showed
it only 230 units or something like this
I show you the proximity I want the
units to be ordered such that all the
units that are the same to be close to
each other
why for labeling purposes I'm going to
show it to you later
I want all the percentages to be near
each other all the participants to be
near each other things that look similar
to be near each other to do this I need
to order it I'm showing you only 30
units there are 24 5000 you cannot even
imagine 25,000 even how many pages this
is how this matrix looks like when you
actually use data shader hollow views
together and they create this huge
matrix and now you can see that they are
g''l is one because the unit always
examples itself but then you can see all
of other resemblances and data show you
I was able to compress it so I can
actually show it to you and you can
explore this matrix again to see what
the values are although the values mean
less now because some of the units you
cannot even one pixel he'll represents
multiple units think about it this way
so but you only want to see you you will
want to cluster the units will be close
to each other and indeed I did this I
used k-means and i did some tricks there
there are several publications at the
end to explain what I did I did it
multiple times and eventually I got to
the point that I had got a better
presentation and let me show you how
better it is look at this matrix for now
and I'm gonna switch we will go back and
clustered clustered which matrix seems
better to you I hope that you say the
second one but this one looks better to
me and notice the first one looks dark
the dark means that there's a lot of
units that when I sum up and create this
matrix I sum up units that are close to
each other and show the maximum so if
it's dark this means that some unit is
better than others there in that
facility but when it's generally light
some only the dark here is here near the
diagonal its figure this means it's much
much better clustered also I have some
other clustering methods some other
metrics to show you how I clustered it
and the like latter the one below shows
you after clustering the number of the
cluster so before clustering you'd see
it kind of not the same after clustering
receipts move so this is what clustering
did and it did to this matrix and now
I'm going to show it to you because we
created a website the work I'm showing
here is not only my own it's with
Joshua's you can find his contact is the
details here we're both work work
independently but we teamed up for that
project and he created the website then
the website actually allows us to use
all of those units that we now cluster
together and allowed people to map them
meaning manually label them the term is
labeling but if you tell the word
labeling to people from their medical
industry they will think about the
labels on the on the prescriptions and
prescription drugs are you getting so
I'm using the word mapping here for a
reason so what you see here is the units
clustered already I'm showing only three
clusters in this website we have about
100 of those clusters each one of them
represents set of units that
approximately resemble each other or
lexically it doesn't mean that they are
was the same but lexically really looks
the same so if I switch between those
you will see things switch so the first
cluster is like things related to
percent of something basically all of
those should be mapped to percent
manually a user can say say I wanted to
be mapped to present and you can see we
started doing this if you look at units
of
that are more complicated then you can
see those are usually associated with
numbers that are not percents you will
see the unit now I'm showing the unit
with escape characters and with as it
shows us unicode why because sometimes
some Unicode characters a user will not
understand that they are not the same
and we want to do the mapping properly
and there are some Unicode issues as you
can see like here's the Unicode issue so
we show that you the unit in with escape
characters with Unicode will show how
many times it is used in clinical
trials.gov we show suggestions by the
SAS system for alternative units that
look close again this is unsupervised
learning the system doesn't know
anything about you units however notice
already we can mark those units that
belong to existing standards
bucum is a standard see this is a
standard and if I scroll down or up I'll
probably find more units
maybe not not in this situation but some
of those units will have here you see
you come out here MS and see this this
unit appears in all of those it may not
be the correct mapping but the system
tries as best as possible without human
intervention to figure out what's
happening and to suggest this for the
actual motto because think about it
someone who's gonna map twenty four five
thousand units or even if it is a group
of people we don't want the user number
one looking at unit number one
encountering that same unit 22 2008 and
thinking oh yes it's something new and
map it to somewhere else we want all the
mappings to be concise so we want to put
all the mappings together so
unsupervised learning helps us do this
the system will also show us the
clinical trials the unit is associated
with so in case there are multiple
clinical trials you will see multiple
all the clinical trials and the system
allows you the person to actually press
on the web button and there's a web
button here that will allow
the user to show see actually the
clinical trial so this is the mapping
website this is designed for labeling
after we have the labeling what happens
well once we do the labeling we want the
machine to be able to learn in a
supervised manner actually what the
units are so if someone makes a mistake
in the future that the character is
incorrect or enter character removes the
character the system will tell you
probably meant that think about the
spell checker as a glorified spell
checker for units so to do this we
started supervised machine learning
I will not go much into details here but
we tried multiple architectures and
using PI visit allows us to create this
nice table and those links I hyperlinks
if I click on it you'll actually see
what architectures we try to implement
and from those architectures which shows
mostly architectures that the deal with
lsdm and CNN layers feed for new
networks basically but there are other
architectures who tried to try learning
to rank also to variations on encoding
with in banded with one heart and notice
we also with the units we also have the
unit context you should
you've seen it before at the clinical
trial it actually shows the context of a
unit so for example percent jail I'll
show you this unit is associated with
maximum concentration so this is another
source of information that we can ingest
into the system to actually try to help
the system figure out what the unit is
not only what is written but also what
is the context so we also tried we also
tried multiple units we also tried
adding inputs sometimes only the unit
sometimes the contexts and sometimes
both and and all of this is written in
one architecture that you can change and
morph there's one program that allows us
to move
they are between the architectures now I
must say the problem here is kind of
tough because we haven't done the
mapping yet we just prepared everything
for the mapping the mapping is the next
stage is going to do we're going to do
and this happens before supervised
learning but we already have the
supervised learning program and how we
do it we use the clustering data that
suggests what is the best unit and
learns the best unit that the clustering
method suggests for each one the units
so it's not ideal but it's something to
start and develop the neural networks
and figure out which one works better
because the mapping process takes effort
and money and overtime while it it's
it's it's easier to code the neural
networks especially with the tools that
we have today we use care as actually
tensor for 2.0 but we went for multiple
versions of tensor fall to get where we
are I'm going to show you some results
and I'm going to show you some of the
different architectures that we tried
and you can see each one of those has
some results on top you can see the
training the training how good the
training was and you can see it for
encoded decoder
basically sequence sequence neural
network multiple lsdm layers lsdm and
CNN combined and CNN layers only all of
those we can do and we can compare the
results and you can see how accurate it
is immediately what whatever the
system's now they actually translated
actually six with a sequence of
characters to a sequence of characters
and later on when you add additional
information about things you know about
the units you can now get a better
prediction the training data it's easy
it's basically the unit the unit's kind
of got memorized by the neural network
let's look at the validation the best
network we we got to is Dallas TM
networks and we had several metrics to
figure out how accurate we are and I
won't go into details
here but I'll just go back to this graph
over here and say when we combine the
multiple metrics of how accurate we are
and those metrics include other things
on top of the neuron Network we can see
that if we use only on the validation
data set now I'm talking this is
basically the accuracy of the neural
network if we use only the unit we're
about 56 percent accurate so more than
50 percent of the time we'll be able you
give us a misspelled unit we'll be able
to give you the correct unit immediately
however if you give it multiple trials
up until 10 tries you get to almost 80%
78% we believe those numbers can be made
much much better but this is what we
start with and again we haven't done the
labeling yet and notice that we try to
see whether it's better with when we add
unit or context so only we look at
context only if we look and try to
figure out the units only by context
ignoring what the units the misspelled
unit is then accuracy is not very good
some 60% of the time it's accurate then
it makes sense sometimes like distance
you can measure with multiple things you
can measure in centimeters meters and so
on and so forth so there are reasons why
the the context is not necessarily
accurate all the time however the
interesting part is when you use unit
and context these input were not as
accurate as we use only the unit alone
this is because we add additional
information that kind of confuses the
network however we still keep this
option open just in case we believe it
will improve when we move forward but
these are like preliminary results we
have now we already have the neural
networks we just need to train them with
the data after we did the mapping we
haven't done the mapping yet now during
the training process I had problems in
actually figuring out sometimes what
didn't why is the neural network not
doing what is supposed to do so I wanted
to look inside the black box inside the
neural network just to see what how it
rains and which layer trains better
which layers get better training than
others and many people outside the
machine learning field say that neural
network is a black box you can believe
you don't know what's happening inside
well I have news for those people it's
not a black box you can see exactly
what's happening during training yes
it's hard to understand but with 5s
technology or how love is actually here
it's again data shadow and all of you
can actually see from the beginning of
training and I'm running full time you
can see the change in the weight of the
neural units you can actually figure out
what happened here and you can do it I'm
showing one layer but they can also look
at the bias and since it's an LCM layer
you can look at the record
we call kernel you can look at all those
and see how those change for our time
this actually helped me find out and
understand that the problem in this that
I had during training and help me
resolve it so it's a good debug tool and
interestingly enough it is not supported
by tensor board for example that comes
with tensorflow
they at least I don't know how to do
this intensive what they'll be accurate
in this again the training process
itself with all of this can be done much
nicer than the whatever Kerris provides
off the top you can actually go and look
at how accurate things out during
training and you get all those nice
hover tools that you can go and see and
you can dismiss or not dismiss this or
that graph so at this point I want to
summarize and tell you that we have all
the tools necessary to actually go ahead
and do the project of unifying all those
units of measure and solving that
problem that I showed you I must say
that the people at clinical trials.gov
the government people who created it did
a great job before they had the website
it took weeks of actually taking one of
those pieces of information that are in
the literature and plugging it into
code now it takes a few hours partially
because of issues like that because of
the style of Babel problem you have to
overcome also some differences between
different entities entering the data so
they already did great but there are a
small team that many many with many many
users and I believe that tools like this
from the open source community can help
them move forward and help us move
forward and actually making computers
understand units if computers understand
units they can understand the numbers
and I'm not talking only the numbers in
clinical trials.gov I won't tell you
more but think about it yourself you can
extend it easily to other things and
also if we continue doing this and
continue automating small little bits
like this eventually we will get to the
point that you computers will automate
away some of the reasoning tasks humans
do think about it today if you have a
unit with the number you have to ask the
doctor the doctor has to be trained for
many years it's a valuable resource is
scarce commodity so it's like this if
you had computers automate this problem
will be so at least half way in and I
want to add that today I no longer do
presentations with powerpoints it's all
in one HTML page like this that's
accessible using a QR code like this and
if you want additional information even
a little pro disability and by the way
the code for this presentation is at
github if you want my additional
information or see who are contributed
by helping or look at additional
publications you can just download them
much much better than having a document
so I think I've conveyed the ideas that
what the project we are doing and how
we're solving it using pi vis or more
specifically holidays I am open for
questions if you have Sam
I mean I work with medical records at
the Veterans Administration and we have
a lot of the same problems even with our
own internal users in different parts of
the country using different units of
data
I'll try to repeat as best as I can the
question so you say that you're asking
what other countries in the world are
doing and you're asking and you're
saying that you from personal knowledge
are dealing with data similar to this
and you know the problems am i correct
okay same challenges this is where what
your words were okay so I can I can
inform you happily the u.s. is leading
us is now the registry for clinical
trials that calico trusted love is the
is the only country that by law collects
this data meaning all kind of many
countries conducting the controls they
are all ported in clinical trials.gov
the clinical trials I was talking about
I was talking about before they are
contributed by many multiple entities
globally I think I don't remember the
exact number but if you click on some of
the if you go to clinical trials.gov
you'll figure out that exactly how many
countries actually show it actually we
should just try doing it and you will
see they actually have it this is for
today yeah so 209 countries the unit
problem
well people currently are standardizing
units and see discs and see this is one
of the better standards out there and
see this case actually I can tell you
again us is leading because all of those
see disk units eventually get absorbed
into something called um LSU new unified
medical language system so part of the
ideas of this project is actually
contribute those AI tools and
standardized units after we collect
all of this back to the entire poplin so
it will appear in those standards but at
the same time have the safeguard machine
learning that in case someone has a
misspelling the user will be guided to
the correct unit so us is leaving from
several aspects because people around
the world are solving it using
standardization not using machine
learning tools as I'm suggesting
currently but in any case there are
multiple standards this is also part of
the problem as I showed and it has those
have to be merged did I answer a
question yes thank you exactly those
words it's text so actually the context
when you goes through the neural network
there are so many words that it has to
go from an embedded layer this is
partially why a lot of information is
lost because a lot of the words appear
like once or twice even within the
context that is provided in clinical
trials of you can extend it even further
currently I'm just looking at the unit
and the associated exact contours
currently not however you you brought in
a good thing the number itself
represents things and some things can be
later done I won't spend too much time
on it but you can think you mean you can
think easily what can be done once the
the numbers are there but this is not
yet what look this project is is not
that old as you know so so the idea is
is to expend as much as possible
currently the next stage that is
critical is actually doing the labeling
if anyone knows of ways of actually
helping out and doing the labeling
please come talk to me and if anyone
sees this video and wants to help with
the labeling please do contact me you
can find my information by googling my
last name or you can contact Josh and we
will help you out of this
well thank you
[Applause]